gordon ramsay is the most popular thing
on twitch right now and i'm being dead
serious about that huge masterchef watch
parties have become the norm but has
gotten the world's biggest streaming
personalities arguing about the legality
of the latest streaming meta
so are we headed for another dmca
catastrophe
[Music]
all right before we get into the video i
gotta remind you as always hit the like
button the subscribe button and to ring
the notification bell if you don't
i actually don't have a threat for you
this week just do it
do it
so how did we get to the point where
twitch's latest controversy includes
xksc ludwig and gordon ramsay well those
first two haven't been seeing eye to eye
when it comes to twitch's latest
streaming meta
like like at all but before we get into
that let's talk about what the meta
actually is
watching cooking shows in recent years
react style content and watch parties
have been big on twitch it used to be a
way for them to fill in a content gap or
to do something while they're waiting to
get into a game well for some streamers
it's gotten to the point where they'll
just go weeks doing that like just
watching and reacting with xqc being one
of the king react andies
for me
[Music]
to know
[Music]
it's a no
[Music]
and you didn't
i need six pancakes pancakes coming up
ebony good job y'all doing a good job
chef that's a team leader right there
when you told me i'll let him know
and yes right now master chef featuring
our favorite loud man gordon ramsay is
the most popular show to watch on twitch
seriously over the last few months xqc
has been peeking at like over a hundred
thousand viewers just watching gordon
ramsay and that makes sense a lot of
gordon ramsay's shows are free and on
youtube and he's mega popular personally
i am partial to hell's kitchen but to
each their own where's the lamb sauce
come on man
i just need him
[Music]
now the big questions are one how did we
get here and two how did our boy gordon
lead to controversy it looks like
trainwreck started to do this a while
back about two years ago and from there
it grew in popularity more streamers
jumped onto the masterchef bandwagon and
viewers ate it up but just because it's
become popular doesn't mean everyone is
super gung ho about it ludwig who
recently moved to stream from twitch to
youtube put out a video called react
streamers have gone too far we talked
about his feelings that people are
walking on thin ice
legally speaking i think this is a
problem that's gonna bite not just the
people who are doing this
is asses but it's gonna bite everyone's
ass on twitch if people don't chill a
little bit because like twitch is the
wild wild west where there is basically
no
live content id system whatever you're
doing live usually has to be manually
reviewed and then stopped if it's copy
written or even if it's against terms of
service and twitch will never
proactively take down something that is
copywritten unless they are told by the
copyright holder so as long as you watch
it live and delete the vlog usually
you're fine to like listen to in taylor
swift's new album or watch home alone
like you could probably get away with it
but a lot of the people who are watching
straight up movies and tv shows on
twitch aren't even deleting the vod
they're getting a little too complacent
they're getting a little too risky and i
think the outcome isn't just these
people getting [ __ ] slaps on the
wrist it could be way way more
catastrophic like the guy on youtube who
got 150 videos removed because they had
dragon ball in the title or in the
content and that could happen now all
this isn't a new phenomenon but ludwig
thinks we have gotten to a point where
it is dangerous for streamers and he
would know considering that he got
recently hit with two dmca strikes in
his youtube streaming career so far in
the video ludwig names xqc myth and
disguised toast as some of the streamers
who are at the forefront of the trend
never one to shy away from things x2cc
was quick to react to ludwig because the
biggest creator xqc
guys guys don't you guys i guess this is
this might take i think he's just mauled
he's just mauled because he swapped car
and that current out of gas real [ __ ]
fast dude didn't [ __ ] it like i said
not in this car and got banned three
times in a span of three days okay
guys guys this is a very rookie move
this is a very rookie take from
nothing course corrects okay here here
on the internet especially with
anonymity and especially on twitch
things explode we do not correct we
explode exploded we've known this for
the longest time okay we've noticed
we've known this since the beginning but
ludwig isn't alone in his opinion shroud
is another streamer who is worried what
might happen if the masterchef medic
continues to toe the line of legality no
i actually am worried about
that
i'm worried about people that do watch
that and get too comfortable because it
is a matter of time for sure
eventually the strikes will happen
you're not supposed to be able to do
that so we have some people concerned
some people who are just playing it down
and then some people like soda pop in
he just kind of wants to watch the world
burn they're watching tv shows man
i gotta compete with that
it's
i don't even know what's gonna happen i
hope i truly mean this i really do mean
this
i hope all of them get dmc eight and get
i want that to happen i really do i want
youtube itself you can't even watch
youtube videos on stream outside of i
don't know like this game trailer for
example
i actually do want that
can't even watch daily dose that'd be
great i would love to see now that would
probably decimate twitch and everyone
including me would lose views overall
but
i do want to see the world burn the next
obvious question is is this something
streamers and their fans should be
worried about well the closest
comparison we have to all of this are
the music dmca takedowns of 2020 or as i
like to call it the dmca doomsday
basically the music industry got real
mad about copyrighted music being played
on stream and went to town with claims
as pc gamer put it in 2020 the music
industry attacked twitch in a letter
claiming it quote continues to turn a
blind eye to the same users violating
the law while pocketing the proceeds of
massive unlicensed uses of recorded
music after largely ignoring twitch for
years the music industry started sending
thousands of dmca takedowns for
copyright violations so twitch reacted
dramatically in october it forced
streamers to delete thousands of old
vods with no good tools to determine
which files were problematic as of late
it seems like twitch and the nmpa have
come to an agreement which is nice
according to twitch the agreement
basically comes down to a team reviewing
reports and twitch offering a warning or
penalty depending on the specific case
of their streamer and their history and
moving clips and bots that have
unauthorized music so people don't have
to do this anymore
[Music]
[Music]
as we know these dmca strikes can mean
the end of a channel one strike isn't
the end of the world but it could result
in a ban however if you get three
strikes or a pinfall as i like to call
it that could spell out a lot of trouble
it doesn't mean you'll get banned
forever right away but you'll become
something known as a repeat infringer
according to twitch themselves and
buckle up for this one quote we will
terminate an account holders access to
the twitch service if that user is
determined by twitch to be a repeat
infringer of copyrighted works on the
service
under our policy a user will be
considered a repeat infringer if they
accrue three copyright strikes
furthermore we may in appropriate cases
and at our sole discretion limit access
to the twitch service and slash or
terminate the accounts of any users who
blatantly and egregiously infringe the
intellectual property rights of others
whether or not repeat infringement has
occurred so obviously twitch has the
means and the history of issuing strikes
under the dmca but so far they really
only used it for music xqc has been
happily watching master chef while
others are terrified of a copyrighted
song appearing on their stream it's like
why we have stream safe playlists
clearly these two forms in media are not
being treated the same
for now what ludwig has drawn attention
to is that there are continuous high
profile violations of the terms of
service that these streamers agreed to
but liz what about fair use oh i'm so
glad you asked i won't bore you with the
legalese but fair use is not a dmca get
ab jail free card and don't take my word
for it dj wheat who is the departing
head of twitch community productions was
pretty clear about which side of line
this all falls on for him he said it's
absolutely not okay just like it has
never been okay to stream music this is
just as dmcable as anything else hard to
see why streamers have not been targeted
but just like music it's probably just a
matter of time this is not an official
twitch take just my own twitch hasn't
officially addressed this but make no
mistake they're gonna have to sooner or
later they're gonna have to clarify
whether or not streamers can actually do
this at the moment as dj wheat says it's
only a matter of time for twitch draws
the line in the sand we're living in a
twitch meadow where viewers watch
streamers watch gordon ramsay on
masterchef
it's a weird meta so enjoy it while it
lasts because it may not be around
forever
i want to be called a donut by gordon
ramsay because i always call people
donuts
you donut
an idiot sandwich
[Laughter]
[Music]
again you [ __ ] donkey
i cannot imagine that man screams that
often and doesn't have at least like
polyps